when you play music
[Music]
you're bringing light into the darkness
i want to teach because i love watching
humans unfold their wings
we're here to get people's attention
i'm giving you reference to an attitude
some people would say
what kind of pedal is that well what
kind of strings what kind of guitar what
kind of amplifier no
it was soul heart mind body and your
vitals
one note and with that know people go
whoa
if you don't stand like that it ain't
gonna sound like that
before you put your fingers on the fret
visualize
this strings from your eyes to your
heart and then you play
[Music]
watch out world
[Music]
the real musicians make the ugliest face
to create the most beautiful note
they're leaving earth and they're like
the gravity is pulling their face like
and if your face don't don't show that
you're making an effort
then you're not going to touch the
listener
we tend to look for greatness always in
somebody else rather than yourself
go inside and get your sound
you can only go into the heart by you
being vulnerable yourself
that's a whole other level of
musicianship
[Music]
i'm colin santana this is my master
class
you